how did I come out to my grandmother she
asked me how many bedrooms were in the
apartment I shared with my ex-girlfriend
and I said one she got it is your family
accepting of having your wife visit for
the holidays more like is my wife
accepting of having my family visit for
the holidays because I live with my wife
also Moy is my family not out to my
conservative Catholic parents but I
really want to wear a tie to
Thanksgiving as I've started to really
enjoy dressing androgynous Lee is it a
bad idea to dress so obviously gay
around them and I don't know I think
dressing obviously a kind of movies not
that straight women don't wear ties
Diane Keaton I'm 35 so I know who that
is
what's your favorite part about going
home for the holidays pi I came out as
trans around this time last year
oh hey Congrats and although most my
family's pretty supportive they can ask
awkward questions sometimes specifically
about when I'll be getting certain
surgeries how can I let them know this
is not their business without bringing
down the mood
oh that's to them not you listen that's
your bod and I assume you don't ask like
whoever this is cousins uncles your mom
and dad about like their bod well I
don't know your family if you draw a
line in the sand because they're making
you uncomfortable you are protecting
your mental and emotional safety and
that's not bringing down the move what
do you say when you're lesbian but your
family keeps asking why you don't have a
boyfriend
distraction bring up a different topic
something like Obamacare let them debate
what do I do if I've come out to my mom
five times and she still ignores the
fact that I've come out to her at this
point you just have to proceed as if she
already knows because she already knows
she's pretending she doesn't she knows
she's talked to her like you normally
would about your life I'm gay and our
family members who voted for Trump how
do I not go insane well nothing brings
joy to the holidays like a really
stressful in nearly devastating election
so what do we do now you should let your
family know if a trump presidency is
upsetting to you I called my parents
before the election I told them what was
at stake for me and actually they
listened so there's hope it's not too
late overall the holidays should be
about celebration and relaxation so if
the family that you were born into
isn't that for you take a friendsgiving
I like run some great movies go home and
then like play my act for your family
play this video play this video for your
family